un gusto estar aquí con ustedes
muchísimas gracias al tec de monterrey
por invitación
es un honor para mí poder platicar de un
tema haciendo si es justamente iba a
platicar de otra cosa completamente
quería practicarles un poco de mis
universo del camino de una mujer que
decreta que nunca hay que subestimar a
una persona que no se rinde pero después
de todo lo que sucedió el 9 de marzo
después de todo esto que hemos estado
viviendo las mujeres por tantas décadas
por tantos siglos todo es esta fuerza
que hemos vivido que aceptar las mujeres
denunció donde para lograr ocupar en la
sociedad el mismo lugar que ha ocupado
los hombres por derecho de nacimiento
durante toda la vida decidir mejor
hablar de esto el día de hoy vengo a
hablarles de que yo también soy machista
yo quiero saber cuántas aquí son
machistas que levanta la mano
y 23 manos les aseguro que al final de
la plática todos van a levantar la mano
porque yo también soy machista y tú
también
es una lástima ser parte de una sociedad
en la que por ser mujer vives en una
cosa absoluta es lástima
ser mujer y por ello que te lo pida
peligra todos los días que no sepa si
vas a regresar a casa que no sepas si te
van a usar de ti es más es una lástima
que por ser mujer el título o la
posición de tu trabajo que te ocupes
sean cuestionadas por quien tuviste que
acostarte para que llegar a donde estás
es una lástima que por ser mujer
tengamos que luchar todos los días por
merecer tener un lugar en la sociedad
que los otros simplemente por existir y
por nacer con una necesidad ya ocupan
así que el día de hoy lamento
platicarles de lo que realmente públicas
del machista en un país en el que el
patriarcado siempre han formado parte de
nuestra naturaleza de nuestra educación
y de nuestro día a día y por qué estamos
tan cansados constantemente de escuchar
a las feministas luchando por que todas
las personas dicen otra feminista más
seguro es féminas y otra feminista más
seguro va a ser revuelo
pero no están cansados entonces escuchar
a una mujer más que muere una mujer más
que es violada o violentada una mujer
más que esa cruzada porque nueve de cada
diez personas que violan salen impunes
yo soy una publicación en mis redes
sociales
justamente apoyando el paro nacional
hace cerca de 23 semanas cuando
empezamos a mover todo este estas
invitaciones a las mujeres al no salir
como decían día 9 na 19 muchos
comentarios sigan de que nos van a
servir que ninguna mujer salga de casa
si no vamos a cambiar la forma de pensar
de los hombres a mí me quedó muy claro
que estamos muy confundidos con lo que
realmente un movimiento feminista
significa nunca hay que subestimar el
potencial que tiene la propia protesta
social dentro de una sociedad todos los
cambios que se pueden realizar cuando un
sector en específico que no está
conforme que no está de acuerdo
levantaremos
y mucho más sabor cuando se queda
callado en protesta de algo en común
porque siempre he dicho que jamás voy a
creer en la violencia la violencia
genera más violencia es un estudio
psicológico que demuestra que entre más
desorden haya más desorden habrá no sé
si les ha pasado dejan un plato sin
lavar y en menos de tres minutos para
decir que la cocina completa explotó o
dejar un zapato después de trabajar y en
menos de tres minutos el cuerpo completo
está desordenado hay estudios completos
que demuestran que somos seres de seguir
patrones entonces la violencia que
también hemos estado viviendo en las
calles por las protestas siempre va a
generar más violencia es cierto yo tengo
un amigo muy cercano que seguramente
habrán visto en las noticias el los
reporteros y por uno de los movimientos
feministas fue golpeado tuvo tres
fracturas través de hematomas cirugía de
nariz realmente un haber perdido la vida
por estas violencias que estamos
viviendo pero solamente las violentas
los movimientos a través de quizás estos
movimientos de evidencias sacuden la
realidad
lo que estamos acostumbrados para
hacernos dar un cuenta de lo equivocados
que estamos constantemente justamente
estamos platicando de atrás venimos
varios conferencistas hombres y mujeres
y por qué sólo las mujeres tenemos que
durar 23 horas antes de nuestra charla
solo para prepararnos físicamente para
estar presentables porque si yo hubiera
venido y me verán levantado y me verá
peinado nada más con un cepillo vendría
represa arreglaba pero tengo que pasar
por todo este proceso para maquillarme
para estar presentable frente a mi
público y en su ser machista también
creer que solamente la mujer tiene ese
potencial para lograr las cosas a través
del movimiento de esta índole es
machista también el decir la mujer que
no puede salir de casa porque entonces a
ciertas horas de la noche porque
entonces puede sufrir una violación es
machista y es cierto vivimos en una
sociedad en la que estar de noche a las
3 contra de la mañana en ciertos lugares
de la ciudad es peligro son más por una
mujer que para un hombre pero el saber
que esa es una realidad también es el
machismo
todos estamos inculcando a la sociedad a
que siga nutriendo este mundo machista a
este mundo de patriarcado gracias a dios
las mujeres nos hemos levantado ya desde
hace siglos para poder votar para ser
considerados inteligentes para ser
consideradas capaces pero exigimos el
valor de las personas por lo que traigo
en los pantalones porque es muy difícil
poder ver a una mujer porque más allá de
sus órganos genitales y verla por sus
capacidades verla por su inteligencia
verla por su compromiso por sus valores
porque una mujer que está en un puesto
alto de trabajo que tiene una buena
relación con su jefe seguramente está
haciendo algo para poder haber llegado
ahí porque no podemos valorar que una
mujer al humorista yo porque realmente
se lo merece
he escuchado también que por ahí hay un
restricción no es justo esta equidad que
se está exigiendo en el que cincuenta y
cincuenta en ciertas empresas son
políticas y dan hombres y mujeres porque
entonces algunas mujeres quizás no sólo
merezcan pero pues como sobran lugares
se los tienen que dar
qué injusta forma de pensar cuando
realmente la mitad del planeta son mis
mujeres entonces vengo a hablarles un
poco de eso es lo que nosotros podemos
hacer constantemente para cambiar la
realidad machista
no sé si vieron un movimiento que se
hizo el twitter en el que tal cual el
hashtag era a los hombres también les
pasan ilegalmente había tantas historias
de vida que te parten el corazón a los
hombres también les pasa que por llevar
falda eres tú la culpable de que alguien
te toque a los hombres también les pasa
que por tu ser mujer y ser la última en
salir está en el camión en la noche
después de trabajar te violen a los
hombres también les pasa que los juzguen
y crean que solamente por su físico ha
llegado a ésta
constantemente me dicen yo hace poco fui
la conductora del programa del evento
súper doble y me decían seguramente ya
está ahí por bonita porque no tiene nada
que decirle tan fuertes a los hombres
también les pasa que digan eso solamente
está ahí por guapo yo creo que es
importante que nos demos cuenta de cómo
constantemente también los mujeres
estamos siendo machistas como también
las mujeres estamos juzgando nos unas a
otras
es una mujer le habla a tu pareja
seguramente le está queriendo coquetear
en su familia es machista porque si las
mujeres nos unimos y nos damos cuenta el
potencial que tenemos como mujeres
unidas centrándonos en en la fuerza que
puede tener un movimiento feminista nos
daríamos cuenta que el movimiento
feminista no es un par nacional no es un
9 de marzo un 8 de marzo o una protesta
en las calles es una opción de todos los
días es no decirle a tu hija que les
sirva a su novio de comer porque él es
hombre es no pedirle a una mujer que se
quede en casa porque tiene que cuidar a
sus hijos y si no los descuida si se va
a trabajar pero a la misma vez
es no decirle a una mujer que por querer
quedarse en casa está faltando el
respeto al resto de las mujeres y el
reina de belleza y me desean mucho que
como no como mujer feminista dentro de
un movimiento social que se está
viviendo en méxico y en el mundo cómo es
posible que yo respalde un certamen de
belleza en el que se objetiviza a la
mujer no cuántos de aquí no sabemos que
a lo mejor esa es la postura que se
tiene en torno a un certamen de belleza
muchas feministas están en contra porque
yo quiero decirles que están equivocadas
el mayor acto en contra del feminismo es
decirle a una mujer que puede o que no
puede hacer es decirle a una mujer que
por hacer algo que ella quiere que ella
le guste base objetivizar se es lo más
anti feminista decirle a una mujer que
no puede quedar así en casa a cuidar a
sus hijos porque ella puede salir a
trabajar
yo constantemente repito necesitamos
lograr este coraje dentro de las mujeres
para que se atrevan si quieren hacer
música son las mejores pero en su
potencial dentro de sus habilidades
porque ellas son las que están generando
y creando en nuestra sociedad en las
zonas que están educando a nuestros
hijos yo quiero hacer también un día el
cómputo de mi vida ama de casa y soy
profesionista y me encanta mi trabajo y
seguro voy a salir a trabajar pero jamás
voy a llegar con una mujer a decirle
salte a trabajar porque tú puedes ir
porque tú vales y porque tú eres
inteligente porque estoy en contra de lo
que ellos quieren y lo único que
realmente respalda un movimiento
feminista porque hay muchos ángulos
dentro del feminismo pero lo que recibe
dentro de la raíz del feminismo es
incidir en una mujer tú puedes elegir lo
que tú quieras hacer y por elegir lo que
tú quieras hacer debe ser respetada y
debe ser valorada y tiene las mismas
capacidades y oportunidades que
cualquier ser humano de hacer lo que
quiera pero elige por ti y dentro de un
certamen de belleza yo también vengo
porque me si me va a decir que como
feminista no puedo
un país en una plataforma dentro de
mujeres que están listas para convencer
al mundo de las capacidades que puede
tener una mujer cuando levanta la voz
porque me tienen que decir a mí que
dentro de un certamen de belleza en
nuestro instinto feminista si en
realidad viene a hablar con la mujer
viene a representar lo que para mí la
mujer significa porque héctor ya
profundamente que la mujer no tiene una
definición exacta somos seres
perceptuales y vivimos en una constante
percepción de la realidad y nada es
absoluto entonces yo les quiero invitar
a que analicen en que estamos siendo
machistas y en que cada uno de ustedes
está haciendo un chiste esto que le
estamos diciendo a los demás tanto a los
hombres como a las mujeres en este paro
nacional veía muchos comentarios meses
chistecitos que decían mujeres que a
gusto estuvo la ciudad mejor quédense en
su casa o algunas que decían viejas de
verdad qué divertido estuvo este fin de
semana hagan cualquier paro que quieran
hagan más paros
cuántos de nosotros no sufrimos
constantemente con estos acosos y con
estos memes y con estos chistes que a lo
mejor circulan entre hombres y que creen
inofensivos pero este un micro machismo
que es considerado inofensivo porque no
está matando porque no está violentando
a la mujer es uno de los de los más
poderosos porque es sordo porque es
invisible pero se siente y todas las
mujeres aquí presentes no me dejarán
mentir sentimos constantemente el
machismo no solamente de los empresa
mente las mujeres constantemente estamos
siendo influidos por movimientos
machistas en el que se le dice a una
mujer que puedo que lo puede hacer que
puede o que no puede pensar que si usas
la falda larga entonces eres mojigata
pero si lo usas corta entonces arizona
que si vas al antro entonces no vaya a
hacer seguro borracho pero si no vas a
lanzar lo que sabes divertir todo ese
tipo de situaciones no les pasan los
hombres en un certamen de belleza sí
pero no te pones extensiones entonces no
no te ves bien porque la mujer tiene que
tener más cabello no me decía tienes que
inyectarle los labios para que tengan
más volumen
la mujer tiene que tener más labios en
el mundo la mujer tiene que tener los
senos de cierto tamaño había una campaña
justamente que lanzaron para niñas de 9
a 10 años unos trajes de baño de una
marca importante en el que los
trajecitos los bikinis traían copas de
relleno
pues es que la niñita para que ya se vea
no sería normal que los trajecitos para
de baño para niños de 9 10 y 11 años
incluyera un paquete para que se viera
más y que ya se note que es hombre
vivimos constantemente abusando de
nosotras mismas porque nosotros no
estamos permitiendo porque todos aquí
les aseguro tenemos en nuestra casa
compras y el compulsión
porque todos nosotros estamos
constantemente viéndonos al espejo
exigiendo no ser más perfectas porque
nos tenemos que depilar porque tenemos
que maquillar nos porque tenemos que
cumplir expectativas sociales en el que
a la mujer se le exige ser de cierto
tipo porque todos sabemos que un hombre
de panxón esto apoya es lindo y es
divertido por una mujer persona es
criticada y hasta qué punto vamos a
seguir nosotros objetivando nuestro
cuerpo y nuestra propia imagen nosotros
nos estamos exigiendo frente al espejo
lo que no le exigimos a los hombres pero
pero somos las primeras en hacerlo
entonces claro que los movimientos
feministas son muy importantes porque
vamos a encontrar restando esta
violencia que hemos tenido a las mujeres
y yo estoy en favor
pero porque seguirle echando la culpa
solamente afuera eso es el diferente
enfoque que quiero darle a mi charla no
se trata solo de pensar en los
feminicidios en las violaciones en todos
estos acosos laborales
qué estamos haciendo nosotras en contra
de nosotras mismas en qué nos estamos
faltando nosotras todos los días frente
al espejo en que nos estamos faltando
nosotros con nuestras compañeras con
nuestras amigas con las desconocidas
porque si nos ponemos a pensar la mitad
de la población
todas las mujeres profundamente hundidas
como perfectas extrañas hermanos y este
mundo sería muy diferente acabaríamos
con tener las campañas que desvalorizan
a la mujer acabaríamos con todos esos
movimientos que nos dicen que no valemos
como ya somos nosotros podríamos romper
con todos los estereotipos con todos los
paradigmas que nos impiden llegar a
dónde queremos llegar
yo no busco a mujeres que se la vivan de
guerreras de luchadoras y que siempre
pongan en mano así porque no solamente
las mujeres guerreras son mujeres
también las mujeres que todos los días
demuestran que son fuertes que todos los
días muestran que somos y rompibles
insumergibles inquebrantables
no necesitamos salir a la calle a
protestar para estar en contra de un
movimiento milenario que ha gobernado en
nuestras vidas
está en nuestra responsabilidad dejar de
ser machistas y yo le voy a hablarle a
los hombres solamente porque el
movimiento es de nosotras y porque
nosotras podemos hacer el mayor cambio y
porque exigimos al gobierno a las
instituciones a los hombres que hagan un
cambio pero si no empezamos por nosotras
en el micro machismo que nosotros
también hacemos no va a haber un cambio
real y el paro se terminó todos
regresamos a trabajar todas realizamos a
las calles y si no hacemos algo real no
va a haber servido de nada va haber
servido solamente de morbo de noticias
para el rating
de algo más de contar
y volvemos a nuestra vida cotidiana es
cierto que tenemos que unirnos para que
ya no haya violencia contra la mujer
pero de verdad mujeres nace de nuestro
trex y nosotros somos las primeras que
tenemos que evitar tener violencia
contra nosotras mismas así que les
pregunto
cuando se salen sin maquillaje a una
boda a un evento a sus propias vidas y
se sienten cómodos cuántos de ustedes
pueden salir sin depilarse porque es un
acto antinatural cuentas de ustedes
creen que realmente son hermosos y
valiosos por lo que son plantas ustedes
se visten para agradar a alguien cuántos
de ustedes critican y atacan a otras
mujeres cuántos de ustedes han sido la
amante de alguien porque no les importa
que otra mujer está sufriendo cuentas de
ustedes no se están valorando como
mujeres al valorar a todas las demás
las que hayan respondido que si son
machistas yo soy culpable también quiero
volver a preguntar cuántas dietas
vamos cambiando el mundo porque yo
también soy machista pero no quiero
hacerlo y porque yo también soy
responsable de que el resto de las
mujeres vivamos un mundo diferente
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]